als er dann aber nicht wie man gar nicht
so genau ist ist mir egal jetzt total
auftreten sehr freuen sich das szenario
tage zurück macht kamen
wer spinnt doch eigentlich jeder ihnen
oder deuce wenn du so mit mir 70
die sondern dass er jeden treffen
mona vetsch 3 dark of the truth station
in der psychiatrischen klinik pro flug
vorbereitet auf alles gefasst das ist
monats mit drin
und schon sind alle berührungsängste
gewünscht und spitz mit drin
bis zum ersten bully lehrer über
menschen ums leben psychiatrische klinik
viele wenn zwei genfer zähler
aber nur wenige während das mit ibi
ihres gesicht gesehen ausnahme ist ein
patient wo samsam jetzt geburt noch
nicht alles gold ein eigenes turnier
nicht auf dich so gut das ist für mich
und mein buch startet vom 14
ich muss sagen das darf ab dem 7
ich bin das biz verwirrt wahrscheinlich
will ich meinen patienten die die
psychiatrische klinik irgendwie anders
vorgestellt hätte irgendwie normal mit
christian
was ist denn also was heißt du hast also
victoria braucht deshalb für mindere
persönlichkeit sehr aktiv und henry
styling zu haben dass das für mich sehr
wichtig ist und die milan-fans definiert
haben oder immer noch definieren und
einfach genug geschaffen hat so okay
aber ich erinnere ein erschöpfter
depression früher noch die große klinik
am rand für den stadtteil waldau kaiser
mit seiner universitären psychiatrischen
dienste bern kurz spd 206 und respekt
und sind praktisch im rallye selbst darf
die station könig werden maximal 20
patienten behandelt
der erste blick wirkt alles hell und
offen aber unser und start nicht so
einfach verschiedene patientinnen und
patienten und auch ihre bedürfnisse und
essbare buchmäßig rät und as bari denkt
immer dass weniger brauchen und warum
warum warum hast du immer unter schock
das ist mein schlüssel als das ist ein
komisches gefühl wenn ich weiß dass ich
mich später zwei chips aus dem werk
seite stück sein dass sie das buch also
nicht so dass er sie inspiriert sondern
dass ihre sicherheit kein wenn sie das
berühmte betrag aber krebsgang hat mit
der sicher sagen ob durch die subjektive
empfinden
jeder moment hält
langsam nimmt mit date am liebsten im
aufenthaltsraum trifft man sich zum
therapieprogramm und du bist leiterin
rockgruppe genau genau und gestaltung
ist brauch für die station ja das heißt
wir machen sehr viele aktivitäten pro
woche ja und donnerstags kochen wir auf
der station und heute gehen wir draußen
zum mitmachen ist freiwillig aber viele
schienen
[Musik]
es stellt sich user der manfred mit dem
schönen auch dialektisch pensionierte
hoch und er jetzt zum dritten mal der
heute psychiatrische klinik
[Musik]
sämtliche therapien mit und die karte
wieder kraft zu sammeln und ja abgesehen
von zwei jungs gerät wir eintreten
pauli und damit beruhigen aber jetzt so
viel also auch das thema mehr
aber ich denke schon insgesamt aber ich
sag es ja ich bin es ehrlich und wenn
sie sagt nein ebenso zweite variante
komme firma unter drogen- und blieb so
den zustand und könne so wie ich mir das
vorstelle schläft und panikattacken
[Musik]
lustlos
wenn jetzt ins bett gehen und das laufen
hätten nichts gegeben
am morgen haben wir aber ich hab selber
keine selbstmordgedanken
und auf der anderen denken in diesem
jahr das leben zu zahlen oder bis zum
schluss aber wenn es um geld geht es
nicht
das wäre ja nicht da die mieter dort
station stiere auf youtube ohne die iren
bei engpässen im garten macht christian
der grillmeister bis rheine tour
nützlich sie das wichtig nicht nur für
ihn wo im job immer 120 prozent
[Musik]
für viele fans und auch für mich ist so
beängstigend die vorstellungen psyche 2
aber wo erfahre kleinstadt einfach
vorurteil zum beispiel caroline nach
einer klinik offenthal bleibt sie wieder
die high und kunden mottaki wies früher
hat sie als managerin geschaufelt mangel
schon tausende von leuten ist ganz
einfach
wir selbst viel mehr kraft und mut und
ab und zu ich komme auch hier alles
patientin und ich bin irgendwann den
moment das geschäft so dass ich tue mich
nicht an wirklich jaja unsers ich bin in
sicherheit von anderen die können mich
schützen von mir selbst ich bin mein
schlimmster feind hier ich finde
freundschaft mit mir selbst werden mit
anderen leuten auch und das ist ein
schritt gemacht
das ist das ist große kunst also nicht
unbedingt hilfe sondern weil mit den
deutschen auch wenn ja warum ist da
schwer haben
ich weiß nicht wie man mit dem problem
also wenn du zum psychiater
[Musik]
das war vor 20 jahren passiert person
geschlecht hoch
also ja gar nicht was das ist und dass
der hut auch bei 82 oder depressionen
das ist ein schmerz dienen um die
krankenkasse muss geduld haben bis es
besser
[Musik]
wir können verstehen wie sich ein abend
unter den händen der brustkorb leicht
anhebt am nachmittag begleitet tages
patient thomas und manfred ist yoga
[Musik]
stil ständige tragen im hofer befahren
und lerne zur ruhe
[Musik]
nach es ist aber gut und da gibt es nur
eins das heißt tiefenentspannung dann
muss man sich überhaupt nicht bewegen
der liegt mir nur und sie erzählte
geschichte musik und atmen in alle
richtungen alle gegenden jedem
körperteil und das ist wahnsinnig
entspannender
zur station könig ich nur viel vom tage
übrig sie zu sehr ablenken oder zu
denken
die friedliche stimmung drückt die craft
jeder seine eigene kampf becker
seelische abgründe längst und dämonen
in der schweiz wird jede 23 mal ist im
leib psychisch krank und lehrer im ring
muss gefühl das ging nur die anderen
pisa noch ein tag auf der akut station
ist mir klar das sind alles menschen wie
du und ich
[Musik]
morgen am 8
die psychiatrische uniklinik vorbei im
auftrag von samsung toni medikamente
unsere für ihre frisch im griff hat die
patientin künstlich ernährt wird
und da in der alarm die patientin bruch
tief es ist ein schwieriger fall
die patientin ist nach ihrer schweren
operation im inselspital auch psychisch
schlecht weg drum haben sie doch lieber
leid bei der infektionsquelle sich
langsam für jeden besucher ihrem zimmer
umziehen habe ich dir helfen
es ist ein hektischer morgen auf der
station ist ihr alltag oder sogar
routine gitarren habe trum hallyday
druck jeder mensch und jedes seelische
leader ist wieder anders und wer da wird
samsa mit der pflegschaft wird immer
wieder aufs neue user gefordert das ist
ein komplizierter sind für die sucht im
alter sind wir diese schwierige fälle
wie anstrengend die ausstellenden dass
sie die jetzt gerade die hier wohnen mit
verstorbenen deswegen noch so schön aber
später die show macht das mache bei
sprachlicher ausgeholt
im moment ist
[Musik]
ob es geht mir jetzt gut ist das ist
super darfst du was man gestern gestellt
ich da noch gar nicht fest und naja ich
noch nicht beantwortet was irgendwie
sieht vor hierzu die häme nicht groß der
größte unterschied ist hier zurückzogen
in der ruhr abkapselt und studieren die
high und der mannschaft lenken wir alles
so gut wie geschafft
also wenn du jetzt du wenn du jetzt die
high waist to the world
wie geht es dir denn das werde ich mit
dir
das war mir gleich zu mir gleichzeitig
so gut was de facto fassen ein tag oder
ihr fasern intakt und mag ja dass sie
meistens am morgen
das wird dann irgendwann mal für mich
und aufstieg group erhöht mit mit einer
psychischen erkrankung erkannt und jeder
konnte patrick bernau hat ich natürlich
angst da dass man sich mit techniken wie
zum reinen ausnimmt und der dicke
chancen über 100 wer wer stellt noch
einen app die woche die chance besteht
dass er psychisch krank wird hättest du
petit stellt ja mit der ex
danke
was macht mir ich glaube dass ich etwas
zu spät pression vorstellen wenn du
keine person resch ich habe mich
wahnsinnig schwierig und ich versuche
mir die als kranker mensch ford stelle
und wenn du so willst du dass du gar zu
spielen was ich mich ins wasser mit
zurückzuziehen
unter mir sehr gut sagt er dass ich
nicht
das ist wo es muss doch jetzt nicht so
einfach
was christian verzählt keine viele die
angst nehmen arzberger arbeitsforen
unternehmen dazu gehören vielleicht zeit
mit ruhm
das psychiatrische kliniken im rauen
spieler sind für unsere gesellschaft
[Musik]
denn die angst machten die mit denen die
angst die macht wie fertig und rücklicht
luft
[Musik]
und ii
das
[Musik]
am sport vormittag ich arzt visite wie
manfred darf
also mir geht es sehr viel besser sein
verrät eintritt aber ich bin relativ
müde aber das kann aber nicht mehr so
schlimm wie unternehmen dort die
tabletten immer mehr draußen sagt das
ist glaube valium und das ist okay
vielleicht haben eine private banken
würden von auf du dich genau also bis
zum zuerst ja wieder wie letztes mal
wird zu einer fixen dosis valium
reingegangen damit wird die symptome
dieses objektiv nicht wirklich merken
die man aber von außen sieht dieses
schlag dann zieht dann also wieder
unterdrücken können
das sehen wir dann wie letztes mal auch
sehr schnell dass innerhalb von vier
tagen konnten wir das beherzigen und
jetzt sind wir völlig auf null was das
betrifft
wie seht ihr fertig darf ich sie schnell
abfangen
die andere tier wäre jetzt zur freien
verfügung aber nicht nur 29 prozent über
medikamente und wieviel medikament das
ist ja heute vor der presse es sei dank
psychiatrie somit medikament abgefüllt
werden dass ich eine lösung ist es so
sehr hilfreich sind und wo eigentlich
wirklich nötig also bloß afghane toni
gard aber sicher ins ziel ist richtige
medikament in der rheder sie rechts geht
dass möglichst die patienten und
patientinnen gut wie möglich wenden aber
möglich dass das gar nicht und bitte sie
agieren oder regnet wie
gegenüber früher noch hat sich vieles
zum besseren verein tritt aber warum
mache dies psychische krankheiten
eigentlich so viel angst psychische
erkrankung ist natürlich wirklich
speziell betrifft die seele dass es
unsere ist unsere überzeugung dass unser
seiner stars denn das betroffen ist dann
wird das irgendwie unberechenbar unklar
auch für die anderen das heißt die
psychische erkrankung an sich ist von so
einer mauer umgeben von ja vom zweifel
von misstrauen was ist da los
wenn dich selbst betrieben ja ja dass
man dass man einfach nicht mehr in
kontakt richtig findet und deswegen
halten viele menschen davon auch abstand
aber das ist eine angst auch vor dieser
situation dass ein mensch auf einmal
nicht mehr das er übrigens niemand kennt
familie und freunde liebe psychische
krankheiten mitunter sogar nach und
angst vor der reaktion von der lieth so
groß dass von der chöre gedauert bis er
vor der kamera
im stationszimmer schichtwechsel
nachtschwester muss wissen was kaufen
die stute tag nach ich sie die ganze
nacht lang auf der station
die psychiatrie ist seinen achten hier
ganz still
eine ältere frau die geräuschlos der
gerufen und auto manfred gottes nur eis
brauche zum zur ruhe
und zwar weil ich finde dass die leute
welche stehe auch immer unser problem
haben die seien alle ehrlich versteckt
nichts mehr
die lassen los und solche leute draußen
im wald ergeben hat jeder seine masken
auf das sagt er mir geht's gut und mir
geht es gut und wenn es sich dass ihm
schlecht geht den käse joghurt wird es
geht schon vorbei und bei jeder belegt
sie und spielt was vor wo ihm erklärt
dass der leitet sitzen zu aufwändig und
wenn du sagst rechte oder durch die
veränderung was christen verein aber wir
bestehen
ich möchte endlich runter prozentig ich
ich sehe du ja ich sehe dass sie 100
prozentig zu mir stehen kann
ja ist denn gut trend ich selber gern
sah ja eigentlich immer lebe die anderen
gehen können ist nicht einfach weil für
die anderen gern da als das für die
erste klasse s für den zweite frau die
tochter die das sagen haben
aber ich fühl mich selber ganz
persönlich für eine ehrlich bin bin ich
auf der strecke geblieben
wie viel müssen
ja und das ist kein einfacher weg
wo führt daran aber so weit doch mansi
die psychiatrische klinik himmeltraurig
fehlers renault-manager wo die gans zum
himmel früher die römer wissen wo sie
sind und wer sie sind und den teppich
jahr gehörige überfordert und hilflos
aus einigen moment wo du bist du selber
moment jetzt sehr intensiv passiv dass
sie dazu nicht vorgestellt machen
doch das ist jetzt mittlerweile
christina ja
auch noch 3d klös die viele medikamente
mir immer noch mächtig viel los
abhängigkeit ist großes thema psychische
[Musik]
abhängigkeit das lied ach ja und das ist
die andere option wenn wir schlafen
schlafen medikamente führt kann ein
normaler alltag für ihre aussagen ohne
medikament bin ich die ganze zeit nur so
kann ich irgendwo anders kommunizieren
und funktionieren
richtig dass ich die andere option so
gut kennt
die psychiatrische klinik vertraut man
alive medikament zum seelische krise
machte jeder patient muss sich selber
anfangen gesprächstherapie im malatelier
oder wieder manfred geschrieben rahmen
hof schaffe was laufen ist und ausland
werde im leibe deuce
[Musik]
langsam und ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen auf der station könig begleitet
manager auf dem weg dort lebenskrise es
gibt einen klaren hang mit langsamer
geschafft haye oder um es als person
gaben hätte wenn man nicht lang mit
ihnen zusammen geschafft hat oder ist
eher unwahrscheinlich weil es in der
stadt und es geht ihnen gut du ja wenn
es nicht wieder rüber sie wieder räumen
müsste man dieses gütesiegels tag die
krisen und beweisen sich besser
bewältigen und mithelfen und attraktive
jobs
der manfred begleitet mich beim austritt
ärger nur zwei wäsche und kunden mit
vitamin d ist vorbei
ich hoffe dass die manfred und alle
anderen dauer bald der gleiche weg
schritt für schritt zurück ins leben
wo sie so werden wie sie sind
[Musik]